joining us here now on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line to kick off hour number
two entering his 15th season as head
coach of the baltimore ravens armed with
a new contract extension that is richly
deserved
back here on the rich eyes and show as
the head coach of the ravens john
harbaugh how are you doing john i'm
doing great rich thanks for having
having us with you man okay we'll be on
board well i mean uh the first uh
question is is it's an obvious one who's
got it better than us john nobody we
know the answer to that one go blue
right yeah that is for sure how's your
how's your how are your folks how are
they doing oh they're doing well thanks
going strong my dad just did a uh a
motivational speech for madonna college
a division two football team in michigan
so i got the pictures of that and he was
his usual you know highly energetic self
uh animated self so he's doing great my
mom's doing great so they're doing good
family's good jim just took a couple of
kids took addie and jack
to the masters yesterday and actually i
was down there with ozzy and we tried to
connect but you know when you're out
there on the course man it's we did see
tiger
saw him saw him uh i think he part eight
selling part eight
but uh
it's tough getting around you know we
had a plan to connect but we never could
connect so you don't have a cell phone
yeah it's about to say you're you can't
text where or where are you because then
suddenly you're not on the grounds
anymore exactly you know
that is that is for sure um so what's
what's it like strolling around
augusta national level it's crazy it's
the first thing you think about besides
how beautiful it is right how hilly it
is
i mean it is like when you're out there
and you see it on tv it seems so much
flatter like the sixth green i mean yeah
it looks like it's a little undulation
on the green it's like a six foot
cliff from the first level to the second
level of the green i saw a guy come up
out of the trap plug it into the cliff
side roll it back down almost into the
trap i thought man that shot looks
familiar you know that's all right yeah
that's right and so it's you and ozzy
newsom strolling around the grounds of
uh augustine
yes yes we were yep we had we had a
great time and we we've done it a couple
times this is our third or fourth time
being there for one of the days and it's
it's kind of a aussie nice thing so it
was a lot of fun had a couple of buddies
out there with us so we enjoyed it john
harbaugh here on the rich eisen show
okay so now you get back and what what
is what is your order of business what
does april look like for you as the head
coach of all time
three things i guess we're finishing up
continuing on free agency uh we are big
into the draft final draft meetings or
next week so i'm actually i'm digging
into linebackers finally inside
linebackers today starting that with
film and then the players come back on
the 18th
tax day and the players are back on the
same day i don't know why it's always
that way but
there's some deep meaning there that i'm
not really i'm kind of missing but i
have to think about it i guess well i
mean uh i guess you're hoping for a
refund right i guess yeah right there
you go in a way there i'm strong i don't
know what i'm trying to figure out you
don't want a penalty you don't want to i
don't know you want to make sure you pay
your taxes
i'm more verbal than math anyway um okay
and so how how do you plan for a draft
when you're you know not top ten i mean
what does that look like for you
you know we've uh it's just a process i
mean we do a great job i think it
started way back you know when ozzie
came in 96 and eric was you know right
behind him as a young guy
you know kind of a process was
established we've been able to come in
and be a part of that and contribute to
it you know for quite a few years now
too so we've got a good way of doing it
collaboration the coaches the scouts
just try to build our board try to build
our order who we like for our team not
always so much you know there's an nfl
board probably and there's a there's a
ravens board you know and the ravens
board is the one that matters to us and
in terms of guys that can really fit us
and help us
be a better team so yeah we'll have that
list kind of worked out and and then
draft day they start falling off the
board hopefully there's someone staring
in the face that you really love when
it's your turn to pick and you're
sitting there at 14 you never know
quarterbacks begin to drop and um and
then phones start ringing i mean how
much does eric de costa keep you up to
speed on how much his phone rings
that you know you're sitting here
thinking you're grinding tape on all
these guys on on who you might be able
to add
14th overall and all of a sudden you
don't have that pick because it's much
more advantageous for you to let
somebody take a quarterback
how do you get uh how are you read into
that situation john well at this point
like early on in the next couple weeks
it'll just kind of as it as they become
serious type of trades he he reads me
into it like you said and we're all
involved in that ozzy be involved in
that steve bashady it's a big part of
that uh and so you know for something
that's a potential thing you know we may
know about it going into the day of the
draft but that really heats up the days
right before the draft unless we were
talking about some kind of a swap or a
player trade now which we don't have
anything brewing rich if that's what
you're digging at right now we're we're
pretty calm right now but draft day
we're all in there together man those
phones start ringing then then the fur
is flying and you know those draft you
know values are being calculated and
guys are all kind of everybody's got
their role in terms of figuring out you
know who might be there if we trade up
or we trade back or whatever uh my job
in that basically just to kind of go um
yeah i'm for it or no i'm kind of
against it and hopefully they listen
sometimes they do
and uh and we just kind of roll with it
why do you think i'm digging for
something john why do you think i'm
digging i don't i mean
you're a news man
aren't you
well i mean you know uh
all right i'll i'll tell you what i'm
digging at um then um so uh
you lamar is your long-term quarterback
though right i mean so yes okay of
course you think oh quarterback i can
guarantee you it's going to be a big
twitter
uh storm when i say this yes sir we are
not going to draft a quarterback
well here's the thing is that the the
rumor mill goes haywire in our business
when something happens that we don't
quite understand you know all
quarterbacks say they want their money
they they either
demand it outright or they you know
expunge their instagram accounts of all
you know fingerprints between them and
the team and
or have their agents send out something
or whatever i've never heard of a
quarterback seemingly if this is the
case to say i'll get around to it
whenever i get around to it is that
what's happening with lamar jackson
right now well and not so many words but
you know he's a unique guy and it's you
know people have been scratching their
heads and trying to figure out lamar
probably for a long time you know ever
since he was a kid
and uh he's got his way of going about
doing things but that's what you love
about him that's what i love about him
uh is it's it's get him on here and ask
him you know maybe he'll maybe he'll
tell you you know but he's
he's uh he i've said this before and you
say it you know it's when he's ready to
do it it's going to become a priority
for him
then we're going to know it you know and
it doesn't have to be a priority for us
right now it's got to be priority for
both sides but we could do something
or we can wait because we know it's
going to get done you know uh when it's
when it's supposed to get done or when
you know hey when it's god's will and
lamar's will at the same time it's it's
going to all fit together so
you know but i do i do believe lamar
when he tells me that man he just wants
to he just wants to be the best
quarterback it can be and that's what
he's thinking about right now and he
doesn't have he doesn't think he has to
think about his contract he thinks feels
like he's got time to do it and
yeah you could argue that one way or the
other but everybody gets to make that
decision for themselves that's a great
thing
that's his choice not somebody else's so
you know somebody else wants to talk to
you i tell you what all the pundits out
there if they want to give me no no
please don't you can call me but if you
want to talk about you know your
particular contract situation and how
you're doing with your salary and when
you're going to go ask your boss for a
raise and all that maybe we could you
know all talk about that back and forth
and have that conversation but in the
end the person gets to decide for
themselves you know so that's what
lamar's doing you know i think it's kind
of cool and funny and fascinating how
all everybody wants to talk about it and
you know speculate on it but it's really
pretty simple i think he's not ready you
know and when he's ready we'll be ready
and when that happens we're going to
have we'll have something so what are
the conversations like with him when you
do how often you bring it up with him
this subject matter i mean you are the
coach and he's a quarterback and this is
kind of
not the lane if you will but you also
are a guy who
i mean you changed your offense
mid-stream when it was time to turn to
him i mean it's clear what you have done
with your offense with him and
rightfully so it's the not only the
smart move but it's been the successful
move but so how do you have these
conversations with him if you don't mind
one more yes
i think that's an awesome question you
know and it's it's it's a it's kind of a
fair one and it's a fun one to ask
because we have done that you know we've
committed to that completely we did
something that is still yeah i know
peter still jury's still out people are
still talking about whether he's going
to be successful or whatever and we've
kind of changed the
way things are looked at in football a
little bit we haven't really so much
lamar has but we've we committed to our
to to a guy that we believe in and
we love him and and uh we're trying to
get better you know we're gonna try to
keep getting better and find ways to
make him better and put better players
around him and help him you know execute
better and all different things that
happen through hard work and creativity
and all that but
we talk about it probably just like
we're talking right now if it comes up
we talk about it and if it doesn't come
up we don't talk about we had a serious
conversation at the end of the season
with
lamar and eric and myself
and he made it pretty clear where he was
at with it and what he wanted to do this
off season and that was really the last
formal one we had uh but um eric talks
to lamar too so you know it might come
up in passing a little bit but
uh i guess the last time i talked to him
about it was kind of in response to some
of the stuff that was printed you know
hey do you see what you see that yeah
that's crazy you know and uh he hasn't
changed where he's coming from on it
he's just trying to work hard every day
yeah i know because again it's uh uh
it's unique and i even said that on the
air here it's just like you know
because he did tweet about it like hey
you know i'm a raven and i don't know
where it's coming from and i'm like hey
it's it's not a you problem it's an it's
a me problem it's a media problem we
can't compute it you know this is i've
never heard of a quarterback
who could have what appears to be nine
figures in front of him saying i'll get
around to it
you just never really hear that so
you know uh john harbaugh here on the
rich eisen show okay and the few minutes
i have left with you i'd love to game
out what you're willing to share your
strategy will be should you be the first
head coach involved in a game with the
new overtime rules and i hope that is
the case because that means you're in
the playoffs um secondly just what what
what does this new overtime rule mean
does that mean
does it mean first and foremost that you
might not want the football that you'd
like to know what you have to do
because you get it second in overtime
john harbaugh
it is a possibility rich i think that's
something that it does become more
viable of an option no doubt
although i still think having possession
first is is still gonna what people are
gonna look at and say is a plus because
if it's a
two great quarterbacks you know if it's
the mahomes
uh allen type situation both both
offenses are going strong both
quarterbacks are playing strong
uh you know it if both teams score then
i'm still going to get the extra
possession and now it's going to be
sudden death so you know the chief score
the the bills come back and score i
still want to be the chiefs i want to
have that third possession so
i still think that's kind of going to be
what people are going to be thinking
about
isn't it a distinct advantage though for
the offense to get it second because
you'd never go for it i shouldn't say
that but um you know it would be very
rare for you to go for it in an overtime
game fourth and eight from your own you
know 20 but you definitely are going to
do that if you have to right yeah so
isn't that a distinct advantage that's
such a good point i mean that's the
point like that my argument on the whole
thing is that that's why i'm not for it
you know and and even though our team
voted for it
they voted for it over my objection
because i don't think it solves a
problem and the you know the only way to
solve the possession possession is nine
tenths of the law it's the most
important aspect of of the game or
anything uh the only way to this we
tried to mitigate it last year by by
with field position which is the two
things possession and field position and
that got three votes so now we're just
gonna add possessions and it's like well
how many possessions are we going to add
and when is it going to stop and are we
going to extend the game into the fifth
quarter the sixth quarter you know we're
going to keep attacking plays on so you
know i'm not bashful about saying it to
you you're my friend i love you and i i
said in front of the whole league so you
know i'm not for it i don't think it's i
don't think it's the answer i think
there's a there'll be a better way to do
it at some point in time but we did have
to do something and i i really respect
jeff luery the eagles and some of the
other teams that are really trying to do
something to make it more fair so
uh that's kind of where we're at with it
but this thing still is full of holes
uh in terms of just extending you know
adding more plays to the game and really
what have you really solved so that's
where i'm at with it so yeah and i don't
know i i haven't really read the fine
print of of the rule um and i think
maybe we're still all learning what it
might mean is it is it possible for a
team
to get it
and go onside kick and that would then
mean if you recover it
you just need a field goal to win
because the other team had its
opportunity to possess it balls spinning
around there 10 yards from where the
kick the onside kick began
and thus um going for an onside kick if
you get the ball first
might just also mean it doesn't matter
if obviously it doesn't matter in terms
of field position if you don't recover
it certainly if you've got in your back
pocket of possession you know you're
going to get is that possible
sure but it was possible i mean that was
that was something you could do with the
last rule if you get the onside kick now
that they've had their possession
opportunity and you're in you're in
sudden death now you just go kick the
field go and win so that hasn't changed
uh if you're facing a great quarterback
you know and you say i don't think we're
gonna stop them all right i'd like to
add a 10 chance maybe that i'm going to
get the ball back and maybe i had if
they only have a 90 chance of getting
the ball and scoring instead of what
might be considered 100 chance if you
don't think you can stop them right
you've helped yourself just a little bit
there but it's really not any different
than it was
before the only difference is now at
least if they do score on a short field
as opposed to a long field i know i'm
going to get the ball back
so i'm going to have an opportunity to
go score and tie the game up or win with
a two point and so so i guess last one
for you on this uh you don't have to
name names uh
were you i imagine you might not have
been the only head coach in the nfl not
into this but ownership or whomever said
let's do it anyway because it's better
than nothing
i were you in the minority as a head
coach in the nfl on not really being
into this new idea i don't know i didn't
do the poll on it you know
so
you have to ask those guys but okay um
yeah they'll be i mean
they're going to keep talking about it i
think and we'll come up with something
here at some point all right coach
appreciate the time thanks so much say
hi to your brother for me i will you're
great love you guys right back at you
thanks for the time and uh i'm glad you
you saw tiger at least for one hole
that's pretty cool you look good you
look good
well take care of yourself thanks for
the call coach
it's john harbaugh everybody right here
on the rich eisen show hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here